the homeless crisis in los angeles is
quite extraordinary
it doesn't matter where you go people
are living rough sometimes intense
sometimes under plastic sheets
and sometimes just out in the oven
the health problems for people living on
the street are as one might expect
horrendous
but amazingly throughout the first covet
outbreak here
the homeless community was almost
completely unaffected
then everything changed los angeles and
california
has its own variant and it is ripping
through these streets
this area is closed for quarantine and
isolation
homeless shelters have had to
drastically limit the numbers of people
they can let in
whole sections are now closed off and
guarded as strict isolation is imposed
from november 30th to december 31st
coveted cases among people devastated by
homelessness went up 66 percent so it
was like whatever
i i called it a special protection
whatever that
special protection was the isolation the
being in the sun
the not coming in contact with travelers
whatever it was and we still don't
know that that's largely vanished
and here we are in the battle of our
lives
the california variant has been
identified by researchers here at the
cedar sinai hospital in los angeles
who are actually looking for signs of
the british variant
but found their own nearly half of new
cases in southern california
are the new california variant lockdown
fatigue
the holiday season and the new variant a
nasty mix
the man who identified the california
variant dr eric vale
says it's the perfect storm everyone was
kind of i think
getting a little bit of fatigue with the
whole lockdown and things like that and
so
there may have been some loosening up
but on top of that
when you have a strain that maybe is
more infectious uh
easier to to transmit it
turns it up to 11 right so the peak of
that surge
the magnitude how high it went
is probably directly related to
this new strain emerging and that's the
california variant
and that's the california area
the enormous cues for the covid test and
the covid vaccine
attest to the fear the pandemic has
brought here
some of the richest and poorest
americans live in los angeles
nothing much unites them apart from
humankind susceptibility
to covet and hear the california variant
what happens if one of the different
variants identified around the world
is vaccine resistant doesn't really bear
thinking about
stuart ramsey sky news los angeles